[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et j'ai encore rien fait sommes-nous
libres de nos choix
non c'est pas une question
enfin pas tout de suite sommes-nous
libres de nos choix
de tout temps la magie le mentalisme et
l'influencent sont liés le sorcier
primitif que je pourrais qualifier de
chaman le chaman à lui seul des
connaissances qui lui donne un pouvoir
sur le reste de la tribu connaissance
dans les plantes pour guérir soigner
connaissance du feu il crée le feu il
manipule le feu est également il
communique avec les esprits et plus
étrangement même il fait parler les
esprits par des techniques de
ventriloquie mai
bien que tous à l'aide dans sa tâche de
chaman le sorcier primitif échoue
parfois dans ses tentatives de guérison
de prédiction et il se met à inventer
des subterfuges des techniques des
manipulations pour garder son prestige
sur la population
la magie et eni on relate au 3e siècle
avant jésus-christ le nom d'un magicien
mentaliste nubien qui s'appelait c'est
aux ir et il arrivait à lire des
informations qui étaient inscrits sur
des rouleaux de papyrus seller 3e siècle
avant jésus-christ puis plus tard les
prêtres égyptiens utiliseront aussi eu
des techniques de ventriloquie pour
faire parler le dieu chacal la nubie et
utiliseront des techniques et des
mécaniques des machineries pour donner
un petit peu plus de relief à leur
mission
mais ça c'était et c'était ailleurs mais
nous aujourd'hui ici avec vous je
voudrais que l'on n'essaye que l'on oui
et c'est c'est un bon mot une expérience
même deux allez soyons fous expérience
de mentalisme
et pour ça j'ai apporté ici des
enveloppes qui sont numérotées de 1 à 5
mais surtout elles sont scellés le
contenu est donc secret mais avec le
contenu de l'une d'entre elles
c'est celle là
vous pourriez devenir millionnaire y at
il des candidats vous faites tous pensé
à des plantes vertes l'a bien alors pour
avoir l'occasion de devenir millionnaire
il va falloir choisir une chaise mais
tout d'abord il faudra reposer la
peluche sur l'un des derniers numéros
qui est ici les numéros qui sont ici
mais tout d'abord il faudra les attraper
donc je vais lancer dans le public les
quatre peluche merci de pas la relance
et pendant trois quarts d'heure il
murray j'ai déjà dépassé de 30 secondes
de mon temps vous vous lever soyez
inspirez-vous me rejoignent sur scène
vous reposer la police derrière un des
numéros et ensuite vous choisissez l'une
des chaises est-ce que vous êtes prêts 1
2 3 4
on les applaudit bien fort s'il vous
plaît allez allez allez levé vous voilà
le premier servi on peut les applaudir
un peu plus long ça prend du temps
allez-y madame alésia lisier les hits
vous reposer qu'est-ce que vous avez la
grenouille la grenouille parfait
monsieur attraper le canard alesi le
canard magnifique
madame vous avez le zèbre zèbres et vous
n'avez plus le choix
c'est le numéro un mais l'un rime avec
la pincée très bien oui si pour éviter
de casser le décor on a mis du temps à
préparer c'est sympa tu n'as plus le
choix de la chaîne non plus mignon brest
à terme l'idée est la suivante si vous
pouvez laisser vos chaises oui soyez en
contact avec le sol
parce qu'on ya des jeunes filles au
premier rang si vous pouvez
je vais vous donner un mot clé avec ce
mot clé vous allez me répondre par un
chiffre entre 1 et 5 oralement mais
aussi visuellement
donc si vous voulez le ca ou encore ça
ou encore ça d'accord ça va écoutez moi
bien rester concentré le mot clé est
lapin non c'est juste que c'est juste
pourquoi le deux raisons particulières
pour le 2-2 oreilles d'accord très bien
tenues ceci comme ceci voilà bien face à
vous que plus reste de vos camarades
puissent se suivent
on va continuer avec vous monsieur votre
mot clé et canard 4 une raison
particulière monsieur non 4 garder sa
face à vous les chiffres pairs son bye
bye mais il nous reste les chiffres
impairs le 1 le 3 et le 5 je vous dis
tout de suite madame je ne mets jamais
l'argent dans la 5
votre mot clé est grenouille c'est vous
madame je recommence grenouille
montrez-moi un chiffre entre 1 et 5 qui
soit un père montrer à toulon le 1
c'était le plus loin dans la liste faut
dire aussi bien le garder comme ceci
voilà un 2 4
il nous reste trois et cinq mâts
attendait madame je vous ai pas encore
donné votre mot clé si vous mettez avec
vous mettez pas de mots clés sur google
il vous trouve pas bien attention madame
je vais le dire trois fois la troisième
fois vous ne pourrez plus changé d'avis
vous savez ce qui vous reste comme choix
applaudissements
le zeb allez-y le zèbre le zèbre une
dernière fois oui le numéro madame 3
c'est quelqu'un qui est obstiné qui ne
veut pas changer d'avis les trois c'est
pour vous je vous avais dit vous avez
bien vu que je ne m'étais jamais
l'argent dans la 5
est-ce que s'il vous plaît vous pouvez
ouvrir votre enveloppe 106 sortir le
contenu je fais pareil devant vous qui
n'est pas d'ambiguïté regardez voilà non
non ce n'était pas le contenu juste à
l'intérieur
parfait vous aviez une chance sur cinq
mais si je vous disais que depuis le
départ un parti du mans vous avez saisi
cette puce que vous êtes venu sur scène
vous avez posé la peluche estime vous
êtes assis sur cette chaise que vous
avez choisi un numéro vous avez été
manipulée influencer vos choix ont été
tronqués j'ai ici un très beau billet de
100 euros
le début d'une fortune à g ici 4e place
pour le tedx de brest l'année prochaine
on vous dira la date quand je ne sais
pas
et j'ai surtout de quoi devenir
millionnaire un billet de loterie
monsieur vous vous rappelez de votre mot
clé monsieur c'était lapin vous rappeler
le non seulement vous n'avez pas choisi
une enveloppe contenant la loterie
l'argent les places allez-y sortez votre
petit papier déplier le jeu récupère
l'enveloppent vous pouvez faire de même
sortez vos petits papiers votre mot clé
est hélas pas montré bien tout le monde
lapin monsieur également votre mot
qualité canard vouliez montrer au public
resté comme ceci jusqu'à la fin canard
votre mot clé madame était grenouille et
enfin zèbres
vous avez choisi précisément
l'enveloppent le numéro que je vous
avais destinée et le plus étrange est
que sur la table ici vous avez le lapin
le canard la grenouille
mais le zalman mais le plus fou voulez
bien vous lever s'il vous plaît vous
placer derrière votre chaise toujours
les quito face au public médusé
enfin on essaye vous auriez pu choisir
n'importe quel chaises et pourtant
depuis le départ vos choix ont ils
étaient libres avez vous été manipulée
influencé ou est-ce de la chance merci
[Applaudissements]
je vais pas vous laisser là dessus on va
faire une dernière expérience il vous le
voulez bien
si on a le temps oui je trouve ça
devrait faire bien on va supprimer cette
chaise et je sens que madame vous êtes
quelqu'un d'inspirant vous allez me
suivre s'il vous plaît vous pouvez
remettre les chaises face au public je
vous laisse travailler un peu les
rowdies sont en vacances vous allez vous
placer ici voilà ici une boîte elle est
fermée on ne connaît pas le contenu on
est d'accord
une voix pas la boîte mais c'est pour
vous je vais vous demander de 2,2 vous
asseoir voilà ainsi et vous voilà je
vais récupérer les enveloppes
détendez vous voilà merci parfait dans
un instant vous allez être la source
inspirante
moi je serais rien du tout et vous vous
serez les récepteurs allez je serai le
passeur ça vous va on va tenter une
expérience je ne sais pas si elle va
réussir c'est la première fois que je le
fais cet après midi mais rappelez-vous
du zèbre du lapin du canard et des
grenouilles
merci je vais vous demander de vous
détendre mettre les mains le long du
corps
voilà parfait de fixer bien devant vous
de vous détendre
il est à l'écouté de vos sensations mais
de ne pas réagir à ce qui se passe
autour de vous d'accord rester
concentrer juste fermer les yeux
maintenant
inspirez profondément expiré sinon vous
tombez encore une fois expirée parfait
madame je vous avais imaginé trois
pensez vous allez surtout y penser à ces
trois pensées fois ci c'est clair bien
ici vous allez prendre un engagement je
vous demande de penser à ces trois
choses c'est à vous de remplir d'accord
ici quand vous avez terminé vous plier
comme ceux ci et vous mettez votre
prénom
c'est clair
bon la caméra va se concentrer là bas
ont posé ça sur la table cacher et on ne
doit rien voir ici j'ai un tableau on va
y voir tout à l'heure par fait lourder
d'inspirer de bien fermer les yeux de ne
pas ouvrir les yeux
parfait la personne que je viens de
toucher juste là il une seconde je vais
vous demander de bien vous concentrez
d'imaginer d'imaginer un ballon un
ballon de baudruche qui voyage imaginez
le ballon imaginez sa forme
quel est votre prénom je ne sais pas
grave les votre prénom si lui pensait
bien fort à vos pensées sylvie d'accord
sylvie à trois pensées je vais demander
à la première personne de bien se
concentrer sur ce ballon qui est gonflé
d'hélium qui monte qui monte qui monte
d'accord il est dans l'espace pensez à
ce ballon maintenant la deuxième
personne que je viens de toucher à
l'instant je voudrais monsieur que vous
pensiez que vous imaginez que ce ballon
voyage ce voyage fait le tour de la
terre et s'arrête au dessus d'un pays
imaginez ce pays elle a une pensée ici
et enfin la troisième personne
je veux lui demander de penser à un
prénom d'imaginer que un enfant
s'approche de ce ballon ramasse ce
ballon et vous imaginez ce prénom
parfait très bien gardé les yeux rester
concentré sur votre pensée moi je vais
essayer d'abord ici
vous pouvez ouvrir les yeux
rester concentré et je vous le dis tout
de suite il est fort probable que vous
n'ayez rien du tout mais au moins on
aura essayé je vous confie ceci parfait
posé le tableau sur le jeu vous confie
le micro également ne dit rien ne
réagissait pas à rester concentré on y
va je vais vous demander de lire oui de
lire parce que vous êtes médecin alors
de lire ici donc j'ai pensé à trois
choses vous avez pensé à la couleur
rouge le pays
italie une raison particulière vous
allez penser à tout ça quand même
oui oui je voulais imposer mais c'est ce
que je vous demande voilà oui regard du
rouge on impose depuis le début un jeu
pas si vous avez remarqué
l'italie est le prénom giulia
si vous avez pensé à l'udf de ces
informations le ballon donc et l'italie
et gouly ajoute julia giulia levé vous
s'il vous plaît
personne n'a mis un ballon ni du rouge
éventuellement ni d'italie ni joue bien
vous n'avez rien du tout qu'est ce que
vous avez vu vous l'a pas grand chose
vous étiez le premier pourtant c'était
le plus facile
bon on n'a pas vu le ballon bien
m'écouter c'est pas grave on aura essayé
heureusement que vous ne pouvez pas
influencé comme ceux ci à distance
serait presque dramatique
par contre un passeur de penser peut
vous révéler ceux ci allez-y qu'est ce
que vous lisez ici wallon rouge italie
giulia je vous remercie vous allez
pouvoir regagner votre place
merci je vous applaudit bien fort
parfait on peut les inspirer un peu plus
fort s'il vous plaît oui oui j'ai pris
des risques que ce soit mais imaginez
vous que ça y réussit bref peut-être
pensez-vous
un que le pouvoir du chaman était basé
uniquement sur la seule crédulité de
celui qu'ils écoutent peut-être pensiez
vous que c'est une histoire de
géographie ou d'époque mais sachez que
de tout temps et de tout lieu les
maîtres de ces techniques
d'illusionnisme ont utilisé ce procédé
soit pour asservir renforcer ou garder
un pouvoir soit pour divertir inspiré
voire même émancipée c'est à dire vous
amener à vos propres choix
merci
[Musique]